hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the world the rapid
championship its Magnus crossing against
linear Dominguez and a lot we said in
the well not a lot of you some of you
said in the previous video that we've
covered by Dominguez that I called the
next great human that he as of 2018 has
been playing for the United States well
while that is true you know he is from
Cuba and he is the the strongest player
from Cuba since Jose row kappa blanka so
III do think the the title was justified
yeah so here at Magnus Carlsen faces the
next great Cuban and Magnus goes into
this round with a point and a half elite
ahead of everyone else so basically he
can he can probably draw this game and
lose the next one and still win the the
title but it's you know not something he
will definitely bet on so it would be
best to just you know win the game and
then you can pretty much do everything
anything in the next game but that's a
lot of calculating before the game even
started so let's just check it out the
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 with Knight to f6 by Domingues
c4 e6 with Knight to f3 and d5 we have
Knight to c3 and c5 now now the
cemetery's on the board we have III and
C captures on d4 with a captures and
Bishop to b4 now a preparing the castle
magnus captures in the center we have
characters captures putting pressure on
c3 and magnus defense we have Queen to
c2 and now continuing developing Knight
to c6 magnus goes Bishop to d3 and the
Domingues replies with Bishop to a5 the
bishop will be transferred to a
different eye agonal while also you are
threatening just night before to attack
the Queen and the bishop as White's
light square bishop is and it is an
incredibly strong piece so a3 magnets of
course prevents it and the now h6 making
some breathing room for a king and also
not making h7 a target once black
castles we have castles by Magnus
castles by Dominguez and now rook to d1
all of this has been played before
Bishop d7 by Dominguez and here there
are two moves that were played in this
position
94 is a new move and night characters
and d5 is a normal but the move madness
place is a new move in the position so
Bishop to h7 check so what's the idea
here
well there's only one move for black
King to 88 and now Magnus goes back
Bishop to g4 and it's a sideline that
Magnus perhaps prepared for for some
faster time controls where black will
have to waste time and take into
consideration the different position of
the King so I one thing being if you
move the rook the the opponent f7 might
become weak as the Knights to e5 is a
move white usually placed in positions
like this so Dominguez has to waste some
time to decide on the best move with
Knights e2e 7 and here we have Bishop to
b2 continuing development preparing to
bring the rook over to c1 we work the c8
by Dominguez and here
Dominguez had some 10 and 10 minutes on
the clock 10 plus minutes whereas Magnus
had 14 with Knight state and here he
spent some 2 minutes on this move
probably considering either that or
Bishop to c7 may be the control a 5 a
little bit better what okay Magnus goes
Knight to e5 and now you can see that
already f7 is becoming a bit weak if you
kick it away then g6 is also a liability
so Bishop to e8 here Dominguez prepares
f6 and he wants to have complete control
over the g6 square we look 8 c1 by
Magnus and now he pushes f6 now is this
one of those cases where you should most
definitely not push f6 well we'll see
now if you don't IG 6 check here doesn't
really do anything just Bishop captures
Bishop captures and after you trade
everything here yes the Queen is very
active but after Queen d7 there's really
nothing to look for here everything is
nicely protected black can either just
to continue the game he can trade on c3
if he wants to you know the the rooks
can get traded off a black is perfectly
fine here if not better
so after f6 magnets goes back instantly
93 and now Bishop to b6
we have Knight the c5 by Magnus offering
a pawn here that and Dominguez decides
to grab it with Bishop captures and c5
pawn cap
and rook captures and now Queen to b3 if
you go Bishop to e3 right away the
threatened the rook also the a7 phone
black can actually capture yes it opens
up at the attack on the Queen but also
the White Queen is under attack so here
we would just see everything get traded
off captures captures captures and see
to that end now look back to see it
captures captures and well it's a it's
an equal position now with equal
material on the board but again if
anything it's black who will be better
here so after this rook captures on c5
we have Queen to b3 by Magnus now the b7
point is under attack
also Bishop to e3 is coming as now it is
a threat so rook the c7 is played b6
also a possibility here if b6 then again
it Bishop to e3 you can then move the
rook and then everything just gets
traded off on d5 and you know it's it's
perfectly fine but dumbing is prefers to
move the rook right away rook to c7 and
now Magnus trades in the center Knight
captures we have Knight captures on d5
rook captures on c7 first getting one of
the defenders away from the d5 square
now Queen captures you cannot capture
with the night because then ideas like
Bishop h6 become possible so Queen
captures on c7 and now Bishop captures
on d5 with a capture Sun d5 and now
Bishop to e3 you could capture the pawn
right away but there's no rush you will
always be able to capture but you also
threaten da 7 point so here domain that
says ok we're not gonna give up any
points here then Magnus would have a
two-to-one advantage on the Queen side
and now Magnus just picks up the pawn
Queen captures on d5 so indeed it was a
temporary pawn sacrifice that shook the
c6 pulling the bishop on this beautiful
diagonal and Queen to d6 now Magnus
offers a queen trade and he can no
longer lose this game which is what he
definitely wanted we have Queen captures
on d6 rook captures on d6
and now rook to f7 controlling the 7
Frank we have
f3 by Magnus preparing to bring the King
into the game and now rook to d7 now
just offering a rook trade Magnus trades
here and here we have a completely equal
endgame with bishops of opposite color
it was in this position that magnus
carlsen and the linear Domingues agreed
to a draw so we'll see what happens in
the final round who Magnus face it will
probably be well he still didn't play
Hikaru Nakamura but so far as I've seen
Vladislav artemyev is doing extremely
well against Maxime holograph and we
will probably have a Magnus Carlsen vs.
Vladislav artemiev in the final round
where if artemyev wins he will probably
be able to catch up to Magnus and then
we will have a playoff for for the first
place between Magnus and Artemis
so that's something only that can happen
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it yes it's a draw I decided to show it
since it's a Magnus is really just
dominating the field and it's well an
important part of the story to see what
happens in the last round and I will go
through all of your hashtag suggestions
to see how would you games to show that
that we've missed so now once again I
would like to thank Michael carrion a
bit spawn rebels Victor Klein a David
Raskin and predator zero for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with one at least one more game
from the finals of the world rapid
championship not the finals but the
final round and then we'll just take it
from there so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Saturday